hello everyone and so for the last video
I made which was how Santa and the Tooth
Fairy exist I got a lot of comments in
the comments section a lot of questions
a lot of good questions a lot of honest
questions um I think some people were
really struggling to understand how it's
relevant and also let's see how it can
how it relates to reality and so I
thought I needed to go back into this
question of ontology that is how things
exist how beings exist in order to maybe
help people understand why this is so
important because understanding this is
going to help you understand the Bible
the world of the Bible and in general
traditional stories into the tradition
traditional worlds much better
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
so for those who haven't seen the video
the sand in the tooth very video I'm
going to lay it out for you very quickly
the notion is that we have this idea of
things that exist and usually especially
in our very materialistic world when
people say that something exists or that
something is real with the usually mean
is something that is phenomenological
and and can be contained and so it's
like I know that a rock exists because
here it is I can measure it you know I
can predict how it's going to act you
know in a very kind of scientific way
but the problem is that there are many
things there are many things even for
the most materialistic person that do
not exist in the same way that do not
exist you know as much in that very
immediate way that rather exists in a
different way but even the rock itself
is not as stable as you might think but
let's leave that aside for a second and
so the idea was that I was just
explaining how obviously to say that
Santa Claus doesn't exist is is absurd
because Santa obviously exists you know
we know what he looks like he he appears
in malls you know you can write to Santa
you can you can talk to Santa and then
Santa answers through these people that
are disguised as Santa Claus
and so obviously Santa Claus exists he
just exists in a different manner then
you know my pen exists or or or that you
know my inner food exists or whatever
and so it was really interesting to see
some of the reactions in the comments
section the main the main opposition to
what I was saying was that Santa Claus
exists as an idea and so a rock exists
as an actual thing but Santa Claus
exists as an idea and I thought that
that was I understand why people would
say that but I thought it's very it's a
it's a little problematic because for
example the idea that Iraq doesn't exist
it's in first of all an idea is rather
difficult because I would like you to
tell me what
is the objective difference between a
pebble a rock a boulder and a mountain
that's not an obvious thing that is that
is obviously an idea which is which is
creating those differences between those
different levels of manifestation of
what is essentially the same the same
thing or at least shares many things in
common okay but let's leave that aside
for now let's talk about whether or not
the idea that Santa exists only as an
idea now this is it's very problematic
because Santa doesn't exist just as an
idea if he existed only as an idea we
wouldn't know what he looks like
we wouldn't know how he speaks we
wouldn't we wouldn't know you know how
he answers and so and then we couldn't
we couldn't interact with him in the
world obviously we can interact with
Santa in the world you know and so
obviously Santa Claus exists as more
than idea and it's really important to
understand that because you as a person
you know have not exactly the same
structure as Santa I explained that your
structure is maybe a little more
contained but it's not as contained as
you think you know I was pointing that
out to some people in the comment
section that you know why is it that I
can interact with you through these
comments in YouTube because obviously if
you're writing me a comment then I am
answering that comments means that you
as a person are not contained to your
body you have extensions you have
manifestations of you which which which
overflow your body you know pictures of
you online you know through pictures of
you online I could you know I could see
a picture I imagined some teenage boy
she's a picture of someone online and
then he falls in love with her
that is absolutely possible you know and
so there are these extensions of you in
in let's say like I said for example
writing messages in your in and I can
answer a message that you've written
that is me responding to you in in a in
a manifestation of you which is outside
you but that's not the only way there
are more ways in which you your self
extends out of you
like your being can extend outside of
your body there are so many ways one of
the greatest ways is your children
you're you are aspects of you are being
imprinted and are manifesting themselves
in your children and it's pretty intense
sometimes you look you hear your child
say something and it's actually this
crazy revelation you actually see
yourself in the child or for example
like I'll see my wife in my child when
my child says something or act a certain
way and all of a sudden you know it's
like I'm seeing I'm really seeing her
through the child and you can't you
cannot totally deny that you know and it
just for the same reason that you cannot
deny that I can look at a painting of
Picasso and I can say that's a painting
of Picasso right his being extends it
itself out of his body into his art and
the same way you can happen in people
your your being can extend yourself out
of yourself into your children you know
for example the leader of a group or the
leader of a church or the leader of a
community his will will extend itself
out into the people that are submitted
to him in the same way for a company
right and so we somehow we can
participate in the being of someone who
is above us we become extensions of his
will if I hire a secretary
that's secretary in some manner becomes
an extension of my being you know she
participates she somehow participates in
my being to a certain extent she's
extending my capacity to act out in the
world and you can recognize me if my
secretary works well you'll you'll be
able to recognize me in her actions
she'll learn how to write the way that I
want her to write she'll learn how to
talk to to to call people the way I
wanted to call all of that is going to
is going to manifest my being out into
the world now it's really really
important to understand that way of
seeing if you want to understand the
Bible because that is really how it is
presented in the Bible
I'll give you a one of the best examples
in is in this notion of there's a story
that Christ says that Christ tells about
the rich man and Lazarus and this in the
story Christ talks about this rich man
who was really selfish and wasn't
helping a poor man and then after they
died the rich man found himself in a
place of suffering and then the poor man
Lazarus was in the bosom of Abraham and
that there's a whole part of the story
you can look it up if you want but
what's important is to understand this
idea that the poor man is in the bosom
of Abraham like how weird is that what
exactly would it mean for someone to be
in the bosom of Abraham
if you kill if you don't understand the
way I'm trying to explain to you this
notion of ontology it's gonna be really
weird for you to understand that after
this person's death he returns to the
bosom of Abraham now what why would he
return to the bosom of Abraham well
because he is an extension of Abraham
right and that's how its viewed in the
Bible and so a father has children and
those children become extensions of his
being they are a hit they make his body
bigger okay and so so out of Abraham
came these people and these people
extend Abraham out into the world and
and and Abraham becomes a principality
he becomes the head the chief the the
principality of that what what do I mean
when I say principality he is that he is
the thing that holds that holds those
people together Abraham is the principle
which holds the people of Israel
together right one of the principles
obviously there are higher principles as
well but that's one of the the main
principles that holds the people of
Israel together and so they are
extensions of Abraham okay and then in
the Bible you'll see for example in the
prophecy of Abraham Abraham at some
point he he gives this prophecy on his
sons and then he prophesizes on each son
and you have to understand that he's not
just
the sizing on the on those sons he's
prophesizing on he's prophesizing on the
tribes that those son will then give
birth to and so when for example in the
book of Judges where or even in the book
of kings and in several books in the
Bible when they talk about the tribes of
Israel they don't talk about tribes they
just named the person so it's like in
you know it's like in Reuben in you know
and and so in Reuben means that it's
like the tribe of Reuben is an extension
of Reuben right and so Reuben has
continued to manifest himself in the
world okay
and so it's really it's it's super
important to understand that but it's
also important to understand it in your
practical life because that's what
happens also in your life if you if
you're attentive you will see that your
children become these manifestations of
you to a certain extent and sometimes
not always your your let's say your good
sides you'll see these weird things
these weird programs that are kind of
popping up in your children and that
you're the cause of but that they're not
always good sometimes you know they'll
actually emphasize they'll be like a
specificity specificity ssin well i
can't say that word specification of a
more a more you know of yourself and so
a little part of you is going to appear
in your children you know and it could
be a bad habit it can be a way that they
interpret that they interact with others
which is problematic and so and then
you'll you'll see it and it'll be pretty
it can be pretty tense and all and
sometimes some really good things too
will see you know like I look at my
daughter then I'll see you know certain
aspects of my wife like a certain aspect
of compassion or certain aspects of a
way of interacting with her sister like
so reproduce some of the ways that that
my wife is interacting with with her
sister okay so all of that is actually
describing how the how the world lays
itself out okay
and it and and seriously okay
overemphasize how important it is to to
understand that because that is also how
a city works that's how a country works
okay and so you you have these
principalities okay you can have a
principal you can have a principal let's
say that that is visible like a king or
a president or or you know some leader
but then there's also sometimes you can
actually understand that there is a
spiritual principality which is above
that which is manifesting all that so
that even if the leader if the leader
goes away then that continues to exist
it's like well why does it continue to
exist when why is it that when the King
dies the the the country continues it's
like yeah the king is dead long live the
king because the principality of
kingship or the principality of England
or France the angel of England or France
is still there even if the king the the
individual who's the King dies you know
once the king is replaced then he enters
into that that that hierarchy of being
you know by which the angel of France is
is still there right is still holding
and in the Bible there are so many
places where we see that for example you
know that's why Christ can in some
places judge cities where he says you
know woe to you it'll be horrible for
you at the end the day of judgment he's
talking about a city and he says it'll
be better for Sodom and Gomorrah than
then your city and and so why is he able
to to judge a whole city you know well
because cities fall under principalities
and if the principality becomes if the
Principality Falls if the if there's a
you know there's a if a city that you
participate in falls in that city can be
judged you know and the judgment can be
on the city but then you can also be on
the individual it doesn't it doesn't
mean that if you if you if you say
something like you
I don't know Chicago is corrupt and you
can say that it can be totally true that
Chicago is corrupt Chicago is corrupt
it's going to hell or whatever but then
it doesn't mean that every single
individual in Chicago is corrupt and you
you can make the difference in your mind
no problem right it's not because you
say Chicago is corrupt that you think
that every individual is corrupt but you
can make that call and it can be
absolutely true because there is
something which gathers all the
multiplicity of Chicago into a unity and
when you look at that unity when you
kind of pull out and you look at that
unity you're able to see that it's
corrupt okay now that that point this
point that I'm trying to make brings up
a very important point and it's
something that I talked about in the
August question and answer period for
the for the patreon supporters but I'm
going to go back into it now I'm going
to try to to explain it as well is that
one of the problems that we have is this
opposition between monotheism and
polytheism that is really a problematic
way of seeing the world when you see the
world in terms of monotheism and
polytheism you know when we have this
idea that Christian Jews Muslims we're
monotheists and then the other you know
before or the hindus or all these other
groups they were polytheists and we only
have one God and they have many gods
that is that is a very it's not helpful
to see the world that way da moneh what
people traditionally call monotheists
classical theists theism you could call
it what's important in classical theism
is that there is we we turn ourselves we
are we are together and we worship okay
we we are grateful to we are we are
submitted to the highest possible thing
the highest possible it's not even a
being it's the infinite right it is it
is beyond being it is it is God is
beyond being God
is is the is the infinite itself okay
and so this notion that we can we can
turn ourselves towards something that is
above everything which is which is the
highest of high right which is which is
which is infinity itself not infinity in
terms of time or space but infinity even
in terms of categories right an infinite
complete infinite right beyond being
okay so that's how we we we talk about
God okay and so then under that we can
say uncreated right the before the
origin like that's that that's maybe a
way that precedes all origin okay and so
then after that in the created order in
the order of things that that have being
in in a more strict sense then there are
all these angels right there are all
these principalities that is there are
principles that rule over certain
categories of existence okay and so
under God we have all these angels this
whole idea of just like that it's me and
God and I have you know it's a really
that's a really difficult way of seeing
the world it's very modern and it and
it's very it's very problematic because
it it creates a kind of arbitrariness
about the world which is actually not
the case at all the world isn't is not
arbitrary the world is we talked about
this so many times the world has to be
filtered through consciousness okay
there is no other way for the world to
exist you know if the world exists
outside of the filter of consciousness
which we engage you know the world with
it's like I don't know what it is you
know a date it's a quantum field even
when I say that it's already filtered
it's a field of possibility
you know it's chaos basically you know
maybe chaos is the best way to think of
the world which which exists or doesn't
exist or is there under you know how we
engage the world with consciousness okay
so because of that because that's how
the world exists the world exists
through this filter of consciousness
then this consciousness these conscious
they end up stacking up they stack up
and so I just as you gather all these
little personalities inside you you
gather all these personalities inside
you and then you you become one your
your one thing I can say you Matt or Joe
or Susy you know that the way that that
works that's also the way a city works
we've talked about this the city joins
all these multiplicities and then there
is there's a principality that is above
that in that you could describe that
principality as a form of consciousness
you know and and then that would be
something we called like an angel an
angel or a principal or whatever okay
and so that the ancient world let say
what we those that we call pagans they
had the same thing they called them God
they had all these different gods that
were that were that ruled over different
aspects of the world you know that
manifest that were kind of the
principalities of these different
aspects of reality the difference
between polytheism in quotes and
monotheism even though like trying to
tell you that's not the right way to to
understand that is that in all right
this phone that rings guys I'm sorry
this is like the act this is like the
the most annoying trope in my videos I'm
not doing it on purpose I swear all
right um what was I saying all right
okay so in paganism they have all these
principalities but the problem in in in
paganism you know in like in kind of
decadent the kind of decadent paganism
that we saw you know in in late Greek
you know before the Greece got taken
over by Alexander and then also in late
Roman times before they became Christian
is that these these gods they don't
point towards something which transcends
them they don't point towards the
highest of higher the infinite which is
beyond their principality and so they
they don't end up being well submitted
to the the the the the highest principle
okay and so because of that it causes
serious problems right it means that
at certain cities you see it in the
Greek times certain cities will will be
submitted to certain gods and then these
cities will end up fighting and it's
it's like you can imagine that it's all
these gods fighting so the Greek the
Greek cities they were constantly
fighting they're constantly at war
amongst themselves you know and so and
so it's not that in the Christian times
there wasn't there weren't Wars
obviously they were awards but it wasn't
like this constant warring every year
the Greeks the the words would go out to
fight with these other different cities
you know where in in the notion in the
Christian notion things kind of bring
together so in the same way in uh for
example in Israel you see that the
different tribes you know they they do
end up fighting amongst each other but
there is this idea like there is this
idea that's presented that there could
be this unity this this thing which
unites us all which brings us together
towards the highest of high right
towards the God of Israel but with the
God of Israel becomes it's especially in
Christianity but I mean even already in
in Judaism is actually the God of all
idea it is it's the the transcendent
itself it's the the infinite itself and
so in in in paganism the problem happens
is that you end up having all these
these principalities that how can I
explain this that you end up having to
plack placate all the time okay why do
you have to placate the principalities I
can explain it in a way that you can
understand very easily you always use
yourself as a as a as a way to
understand this okay because there's an
analogy always an analogy between the
way that we exist as a person and the
way that lets say societies exist right
there's this strict analogy and it can
help us to understand how that works and
so you yourself is the same in you you
have all these thoughts you have all
these desires you have all these
personalities okay you have multiple
personalities inside you okay and and
and and you have all these crazy
thoughts which don't fit together right
you can you can hate someone and love
them sadly that can happen almost at the
same time you can have all these
contrary things inside you that that
that manifests themselves all at once
okay and so ideally what you need to be
able to do is you'll be able to submit
all those multiplicities right to your
heart right a good way of seeing it was
to Christ in you to the transcendent you
know of which you are an image right if
you can do that then everything will lay
itself out and will will kind of exist
in the way it's supposed to exist right
and so a good way to understand let's
say these this idea of principalities
which which do not submit themselves to
a transcendent to the transcendent
is to see it the way the church father
said it is also what they said when the
Hellenistic world became Christian they
started to say that the Greek gods were
demons fallen angels and demons all
these this type of imagery and that's
really the best way to understand it
right so there's there are all these
principalities that manifest different
aspects of the world okay
and so in Christianity had this idea
that there was a war in heaven right so
there's this war in heaven and some of
the angels submitted themselves to the
highest and some of the angels rebelled
against the highest and went their own
way and did their own thing okay and so
that's really the best way to understand
it you know there are all these
principalities and the principalities
which submit themselves to the highest
they end up manifesting the positive
aspect of that of that principality and
so they lay themselves out you know in
in a normal hierarchy pointing towards
that infinite okay but if and but but
those that didn't they they they pull
the world apart okay so different
different principalities if they're seen
as competing with each other will pull
the world apart right and so let's say
Athens you know this idea of let's a
reason and democracy and
and the individual right on one side and
then you have Sparta which was will
strength you know power and then those
two they there if those principalities
cannot be seen as both being let's say
both being too in different aspects of
something which points towards something
higher what's gonna happen they're gonna
fight right they're gonna fight and and
it's going to pull the world apart okay
now in you is the same okay
so so this can help you understand so
many things about about the Christian
tradition these fallen angels right
these these these demons they become
aligned with they become representatives
of your passions and that's why we say
things like the demon of gluttony right
the demon of pride the demon of luxury
okay because that's exactly how it
manifests itself in you so you in you
you have all these desires you have a
desire to eat you have a desire to have
sex you have a desire to to to protect
yourself right to to not to not let
yourself get killed by other people all
these desires exist in you okay
when those desires are not united to
Christ in you to the higher aspect of
yourself okay then what's going to
happen is it's gonna pull you apart and
what are you gonna have to do you're
going to have to placate those demons
right and you experience this all the
time right I always use the idea of the
the idea of the belly the belly is is
really the most immediate way to
understand it you know you you you have
you wanna eat chocolate cake right and
you you know you know you're a little
bit overweight you know that that that
you know you don't need it you're not
really hungry you just want to eat that
piece of chocolate cake okay and so what
do you do this desire is pulling you
write this principality right this
little personality this demon is pulling
you and it's a demon right it's a demon
because it's not just you it has a
cosmic reality because I know that Joe
is can experience the same thing and you
know Susie can experience the same thing
you know because we we share this demon
manifest itself in different ways it has
a has a coherence okay
and so this demon of gluttony this
Principality of gluttony is pulling me
to eat the chocolate cake now what can I
do now I'm in I'm an attention now
either if I'm able to surmount my desire
and to submit it to the higher aspect of
myself right then I am going to make I'm
going to submit that principality it's
going to become a normal it's not going
to be ruled by the demon anymore
it'll just be normal desire because
we're eating as a normal desire there's
nothing wrong with with being hungry
being hungry is a completely natural
desire right but another way to get rid
of that desire what is it everybody
knows what it is to eat that chocolate
cake is to placate the demon right so if
I play get the demon then the demon goes
away for a while but it's a it's a
dangerous game because if I placate the
demon then I know that it's gonna come
back right and so it's like I'm actually
I'm dealing it with it right now but I
know it's gonna come back okay and so
that's that's a guy's that's how the
world works out think think of it in an
in at it at the other level think of it
at the level of a family right so I'm
the Principality okay I'm I'm the
principal of as a father I'm the head of
the household right I'm the principal of
the family and so then I have these
manifestations which extend which extend
out of me these smaller principles which
are my my children right and so those
children when we're when they're united
when we're all united and and and and
where we're actually not they're not
just looking towards me but they're
looking towards me as I'm also looking
higher you know and in trying to bring
my family to some to two virtues into
virtues and into something that's higher
than me then all of that is gonna make
it work but then I can have let's say my
child who let's use the same example as
the candy it's like dad can I have some
candy dad can I have some candy and it's
like I know that they don't need the
candy because they've had enough and you
know it's
and I know that if they eat the candy
it's not good for them and also it's
gonna make them excited it's gonna make
them annoying but it's like I I have the
same problem I had the same problem it's
like I can either bring the child and
it's gonna be it might be difficult have
to bring the child into alignment or I
can play Kate my child and I could just
give them the candy and I know Ben and I
know I know that if I do that I'm going
to solve the problem for now but what
I'm going to do is I'm going to set it
into a loop and it's going to come back
and I'm gonna have to placate the kid
again and I'm gonna and that's that's
how you get spoiled spoiled children and
then those spoiled children what do they
do they rule they become like demons
alright not saying kids are demons but
they become like demons in the sense
that they're able to then not because
they're there they're there they're a
wild principality they they end up
pulling you and they're going to they
could even rule over you right they
could even become like a like a
something which is not supposed to rule
over you
but then will totally rule over you and
then you will it'll be like an upside
down world well you will be submitting
yourself to your children's desires and
you everything you do will be there to
placate their desires you can have to
feed the the monster okay and so it's
really important to kind of understand
how that works and so when I when I it's
more important to understand this basic
way that the world exists right and not
get too caught up on the idea of Santa
Claus or the Tooth Fairy though
obviously Santa Claus exists and the
Tooth Fairy exists but it's mostly
important to understand that you know
when we talk about God and angels and
demons and OH and all these things you
know it's not arbitrary this is really
how the world exists and you can
understand that that's how the world
exists because it's like the language
those that language has been so ruined
for us that we need to look closer to us
we need to look at our families at
society's how societies lay themselves
out how we are extensions of higher
beings
in terms of of societies or in terms of
families because a family is a higher
being than the individuals of the family
when we can kind of understand how that
works then we can start to see once
again what it is that these these angels
these demons what is it that they're
referring to and how is it that that if
the in of the hierarchy of angels which
is presented and in the dinies and
corpses in in the the area appear there
yep a guide how that is really an
example it's really showing us how the
world lays itself out and how the effect
of understanding that consciousness is
the key consciousness is the key once
you understand that the world exists
through consciousness and then all of a
sudden these these this type of language
is going to start to make sense to you
once again and it's not just going to be
something arbitrary that you have to
believe in you know like you believe in
some arbitrary divine being no that's
how the world exists all right guys so I
hope you enjoyed this I'm going I'm
leaving for Seattle very soon in a few
days and I'm going to be in two places
I'm going to be in on the 11th of August
I'm going to be giving a talk at a
church in Seattle st. John Chrysostom's
Catholic Byzantine church and shadow and
then on the 15th I'm going to give a
talk at st. John's Church in Montesano
Washington so I'm going to put some some
links down in the description so that if
you're in the Seattle area you'll know
where to go and so it would be great to
see some of you guys there because you
know I'm I'm on the East Coast but on
the west coast we good to meet some of
you there so all right I will see you
soon
if you enjoyed this content in our
exploration of symbolism get involved I
love to read your comments in the
comment section below please go ahead
and share this on social media to all
your friends and also please consider
supporting us financially on patreon
you'll find a link to the patreon page
into this
in below